rettungshubschrauber im anflug auf wesel
in nordrhein westfalen dort ist am
samstagmittag ein ultraleichtflugzeug
auf ein wohnhaus gestürzt
nach ersten angaben sind dabei drei
menschen ums leben gekommen
bei zwei der opfer handelt es sich um
die besatzung des zweisitzer flugzeugs
so ein sprecher der feuerwehr zu bild
alle drei opfer sind erwachsene
claudia pauli sah den absturz und eilte
sofort zur hilfe
ich hab es mitgekriegt service gesehen
den einschätzungen habe ich dann gehört
harris haus waren brennen menschen die
wahren aufgelöst die stark war
wir haben geholfen dass sie damit weg um
eine explosion gebe ich gesehen zusammen
hingegangen mittlerer wald neben vorbei
die feuerwehr konnte den brand des haus
das am nachmittag unter kontrolle
bringen nach angaben der polizei war das
ultraleicht-flugzeug mit zwei insassen
am flugplatz in mal gestartet und zu
einem zwischenstopp in wesel gelandet
hier hat unser reporter axel schack
allee pzta entschuldigung ist jetzt vor
ort in wesel alex was spielt sich dort
jetzt gerade ab zunächst einmal das
feuer ist gelöscht die feuerwehr ist
gerade mit nachlöscharbeiten beschäftigt
im hintergrund arbeiten auch die
rettungshunde um den abgestürzten
rettungsschirm suchen die spürhunde
gerade ob da irgendwelche anzeichen gibt
ob von verletzten
aber das ist bisher nicht der fall neben
mir steht jetzt der pressesprecher der
polizei
peter reuters können sie uns sagen was
weiß man über den unfallhergang bisher
ja nach bisherigen erkenntnissen kam es
heute hier in wesel im bereich
emmericher straße ferbers kampf zum
absturz eines ultraleichtflugzeuges was
im weiteren verlauf in das dach eines
wohnhauses stürzte die erst
eintreffenden kräfte stellten fest dass
das dach des hauses in brand geraten war
durch feuerwehrkräfte wurde
insgesamt drei tote personen aus dem
haus geborgen
die ermittlungen zur unfallursache
dauern noch an
es gab gerüchte dass dieses dieses
ultraleichtflugzeug mit einem
heißluftballon irgendwie in berührung
geraten soll was kann man dazu sagen was
weiß die polizei
also das kann ich ihnen nicht bestätigen
gibt es schon hinweise um was für
irgendwelche wassers für opfer sind also
ob das die piloten sind ob das die
insassen von diesem flugzeug sind oder
anwohner des hauses also zu den
verletzten oder getöteten personen gibt
es aktuell noch keine verlässlichen
informationen bis auf eine person eine
junge frau 39 oder 40 jahre alt die dort
tot geborgen werden konnte die identität
der anderen im haus gefundenen personen
steht noch nicht gänzlich fest in der
wohnung soll sich auch ein kind zwei
jahre alt befunden haben wie geht es
diesem kind ja so nach meinen
erkenntnissen ist das kind leicht
verletzt und wird durch angehörige
betreut
wir haben auch eine vielzahl von
opferbetreuung seelsorgern hier vor ort
also das kind ist in obhut von
familienangehörigen welche maßnahmen
werden jetzt noch seitens der polizei
getroffen sobald die unglücksstelle
freigegeben wird von der feuerwehr
ja also die kriminalpolizei und das
luftfahrtamt werden sich natürlich auf
ermittlungen gegeben zur unfallursache
damit fest steht irgendwann was zu
diesem abschluss geschehen geführt hat
aber die ermittlungen dahingehend dauert
halt an und im moment gehört das haus
glaube ich auch noch nicht betreten
vielen dank erstmal ja und dramatisch
war es auch natürlich für die feuerwehr
die war sehr schnell hier vor ort und
neben mir steht jetzt der chef raketen
in der leiter der feuerwehr robert
meyboom können sie mir erzählen wie
dramatisch die ersten minuten waren für
die einsatzkräfte
ja es ist natürlich klar wenn man zu
einer einsatzstelle gerufen wird wo ein
flugzeug in ein gebäude gestürzt ist
brand im dachgeschoss man weiß natürlich
was man in der wohnung vor findet aber
die ersten kräfte sind so vorteil hin
vorgedrungen und konnten die frau und
das kleinkind das bereits bergen retten
und ist natürlich im ersten moment immer
so ein bisschen unübersichtlich aber
stellte sich dann relativ schnell raus
also
löscharbeiten erreichen umfang
erforderlich waren weil natürlich durch
auslaufende kraftstoff die wohnung
schlagartig in brand gesetzt worden ist
und die entsprechende maßnahmen sind
dann eingeleitet worden
ich habe es ja eben schon angesprochen
rettungshunde sind im einsatz was machen
diese 100 jetzt genau die suchen einmal
die gegend ab weil die sind teile von
einem fallschirm oder dem fallschirm
gefunden worden
diese ultraleichtflieger hatte ein
rettungs fallschirm wie das bei diesen
fliegern eigentlich üblich ist der auch
wohl ausgelöst hat aber der flieger ist
ein trotzdem dach gestürzt und das muss
jetzt da wird weitergesucht nach
nachteilen oder ob da sonst noch mal
beteiligt war
sie sprachen soeben den heißluftballon
an den können wir auch nicht bestätigen
da so das war nicht aber es sind eben
teile in der nähe gefunden worden
und da wird natürlich gesucht und nach
gesichert vielen dank erstmal ja und was
waren weiß es handelt sich hierbei um
ein mehrfamilienhaus sieben parteien
wohnen in diesem haus 15 anwohner sind
dort gemeldet dass zu dem stand zu dem
mehrfamilienhaus und in den nächsten
minuten sollen auch die leichen geborgen
werden